aujourd'hui je parle d'un tout nouveau
produit je vous emmène dans mon salon si
ça résonne un peu désolé si le son n'est
pas complètement optimale je veux qu une
des dernières télé de samsung
[Musique]
je vous présente la samsung
q l'aide qu 85 m 65 pouces de diagonale
163 cm je sais pas ça vous parle
mais le truc en fait c'est un vrai
monstre vous voyez à côté j'ai l'air
tout petit le truc est et nord je peux à
peine les bras écartés comme ça le
touche et c'est vraiment une dalle
qu'est faramineuses qui est vraiment
énorme et qui est franchement il permet
lancer une nouvelle dalle de cette année
de samsung et ça ne saoule continue sa
progression au niveau l'été ça me semble
ça fait longtemps qu'ils sont très très
bons dans le domaine de la télé il
continue devraient moins progresser avec
cette calculette c'est vraiment
incroyable
notamment sur les reflets ça c'est pour
expliquer il ya énormément de points
positifs c'est la toute première fois en
plus que je teste une télé ça c'est cool
merci samsung de me donner l'opportunité
justement de faire un tout premier test
de télé directement comme ça entre est
très grand alors chez moi c'est un peu
trop je dois le reconnaître c'est un
petit peu trop grand en bas vous allez
voir genia questions de base j'ai pas pu
coller à votre radiateur donc par
rapport à mon temps de mur c'est quand
même un peu grand après il existe
différentes tailles mais c'est vrai que
si vous avez une très belle pièce vous
allez belle dimension c'est lé là est
vraiment incroyable
donc ça que le premier tour qui saute
aux yeux quand on la voit comme ça c'est
les contrastes les couleurs la
luminosité c'est un écran qui est
vraiment hyper lui mais de la gemmi un
éclairage d'autres ici on ne rit pas
forcément mais ça tabasse il ya quand
même beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup lumière
et la luminosité est vraiment optimales
là je vous ai mis l'ambiance vonn qui
devait expirer dans quelques instants ce
que c'est une espèce de de fonds d'écran
pour t'aider
on ya pas mal de deux différentes
possibilités là dessus je vous détailler
je vous montre un peu comme en
indivision montrer ce qu'on peut faire
avec
mais avant je fais un petit tour du
propriétaire bien évidemment on va
parler ici d'un écran 4 ke hd avec une
résolution de 3840 parle 2160 pixels
c'est un écran 4 cas c'est une dalle 4k
fait pour voir dans quatre cas bien
évidemment toutes les sources sont pas
en 4k mois en plus chez moi j'ai pas de
kaka j'ai eu une box et une arrivée
internet un peu moyen en adsl donc je
suis plutôt en 1080p et des fois tout
petit peu moins donc ce fait l'écran ce
qui va faire du hull skylink
en gros il va prendre ma qualité d'image
dans le ciel un peu plus basses même si
on va dire qu'on est en 1080p et ivanov
sky les en 4k ça nous permettra de
profiter d'une plus grande image avec
une meilleure qualité
l'obs kyle est quand même relativement
cool c'est vrai que des fois on voit un
tout petit peu lissage mais c'est
vraiment très
très très très faim à côté de ça chez
moi je vous dis j'ai de l'adsl
il n'y a pas de fibres donc ça rame
franchement budget que vous lui mettez
du contenu 4k vous afficher des images
comme ça le rendu est vraiment sublime
bien évidemment derrière vous avez ce
qu'il faut vous avez pour tous mpt
processeur quatre cas qui va faire tout
ce boulot et qui marche
merveilleusement bien ce qui va ce
moment bien soit et laissait déjà les
différents angles de vision pouvez vous
mettre à différents endroits
vous avez toujours une qualité qui
complètement optimale alors voyez là on
devine sais pas si vous voyez ici là
c'est mon éclairage qui situe ici de
l'autre côté
donc là on voit un peu mais il est
vraiment ténue et lorsque vous mettez en
face ce qui est vraiment hyper
impressionnant avec cet écran c'est que
vous n'avez absolument aucun reflet j'ai
une autre fenêtre qui est de l'autre
côté ici et là vous ne voyez absolument
rien vous avez absolument aucun reflet
vous avez vraiment une qualité qui est
absolument incroyable et vous pouvez
vous mettre sous tous les angles
regardez je veux mettre par la up alors
là quand je mets comme ça on va
commencer à deviner et à voir les
reflets ils paraissent un peu plus dorée
que ce qu'on verrait de façon un peu
normal il faut vraiment se mettre sur le
côté parce que quand vous mettez en face
pour mettre ce que vous voulez vous avez
absolument aucun reflet ça c'est
vraiment un très très très gros boulot
qui a été fait sur cette télé cette
année et l'autre qui est vachement bien
si vous avez pas mettre tous vos
connectique directement sur votre écran
vous avez un boîtier déporté qui
s'appelle onevision qui vachement bien
ce qui fait que vous avez juste un tout
petit câble qui fait cinq mètres qui
parle de votre écran jusqu'à votre
boîtier vous le mettez où vous voulez
quasiment invisible et tout est situé là
dedans alors moi je devais me saoule
meubles parce que j'ai pas fixé ma télé
autrement mais voyez vous avez ça existe
mais si tu es juste là là je sais pas si
on va bien voir un différend vous
emmènent à l'arrière du boîtier vous et
des connectiques antenne vous avez d'une
sortie optique vous avez aussi une
entrée lan vous avez quatre câbles hdmi
composite branché et vous avez ici votre
port wan connect que vous avez connecter
directement à votre téléviseur et c'est
ce petit câble là vous voyez qui va
suivre tout son chemin et qui vient
ensuite se plonger directement si
derrière votre écran le faisait tout un
chemin qui est fait geslin qui peut
bouger qui passe derrière c'est
vachement bien installé c'est
extrêmement discret bon par contre
regardez pas chez moi derrière c'est
vraiment le bazar du câble et voyez le
truc est vraiment transparent est ce qui
est cool c'est que lorsque vous allez à
fixer contre mur par exemple
vous allez juste à voir ce tout petit
câble qui va venir lécher votre mur
quasiment invisible et qui va ajouter
vous avez cinq mètres qui vient jusqu'à
votre boîtier ici vous le connecter ça
marche tout seul c'est vraiment très
très facile à brancher l'écran qu elle
je sais pas si vous savez comment ça
fonctionne
vous avez des nanoparticules
inorganiques qui vont vous donner 30 %
de luminosité en plus vous avez hdr qui
beaucoup mieux traités vous avez en
volume que l'on aimé triki complètement
optimale les couleurs ne ternissent pas
dans le temps vous n'avez pas de
marquage et moi je perds ma voix ça
m'apprendra se faire un petit peu trop
la fête
le processeur très tournés cet écran a
de l'intelligence artificielle a détecté
enrôler les scènes que vous êtes en
train d'afficher pour complètement
adapté mais la lumière le contraste la
saturation tout pour vous et une image
qui est complètement optimisé mais truc
qui va chemin cool avec ça si vous
pouvez tout piloté avec cette seule
petite télécommande et l'expérience
utilisateur est hyper cool vous tourner
sous tyson je vous montre installé dire
ce que vous en pensez
lorsque vous êtes dans votre menu
principal vous allez pouvoir faire pas
mal de choses regarder vous allez si
tous vos paramètres de pouvoir régler
pas mal de choses ce paramètre est pas
mal de choses directement sans votre
télé là dessus vous avez ensuite votre
source
vous avez les différentes recherches des
applications ce que vous voulez vos
applications avec notamment dax note si
vous connaissez un service de cloud
gaming français qui est plutôt sympa et
vous avez en plus apple tv qui arrivé
depuis très peu de temps donc c'est
plutôt bien qu'il est compatible apple
airplay y deux prêts vous avez votre
ambiante mode alors l'ambiante mode vous
permet je dirais de d'utiliser votre
téléviseur votre écran lorsque vous
regardez pas la télé alors c'est un peu
plus énergivores c'est pas hyper hyper
hyper green par contre vous avez des
fonds des fonds d'écran vous avez
différents thèmes vous avez up mais je
mets des oeuvres d'art vous avez vos
albums vous affichez vos propres photos
vote des causes différentes éditions
enfin un truc est quand même assez
intéressant en plus ce qui est bien et
si j'ai pas trop le faire c'est que
lorsque vous avez un mur qui est d'un
seul tenant moi j'ai un petit décalage à
côté donc c'est pas terrible
vous venez vous prenez une photo avec
l'application smart things avec votre
téléphone
ça va vous reconnaître votre fond et ça
vous créer des effets avec votre fonds
incrusté à votre télé en gros vous ça va
faire servir encore plus créé une
station d'immersion avec un écran qui
est quasiment invisible bon le truc
assez sympa mais malheureusement chez
moi j'ai pas la pièce qui va
parfaitement bien pour ça donc on s'en
rend pas trop compte vous avez samsung
tv plus vous avez dit
hers molotov pv vous avez netflix vous
avez enfin il faut les abonnements quand
même acheté à préciser si vous n'êtes
pas d'abonnement netflix ça ne marchera
pas mais vous pouvez laborde quoi comme
ça c'est pratique prennent vidéo avec
amazon rmc sport google play movie ntv
rakuten tv youtube plutôt bien nike
canal ocs smart singh pour aider de vos
objets de l'écosystème samsung ensemble
les galeries internet est vraiment cool
et en plus ce qui est bien c'est que
vous avez bixby qui est intégré
directement là dedans bigby ouvre moi
monsieur greu sur youtube elle a
toujours du mal avec monsieur grenet
affiché groulx large et une astuce si ça
vous arrive affiche moi monsieur sur
youtube
voilà j'ai monsieur et ensuite je tapais
membres manuellement ça marchera encore
mieux à me voilà monsieur greu je vous
mets un petit test et vous allez voir
c'est vachement bien parce que moi mes
vidéos elles sont tournées en 1080p et
ça me faire un autre qui est ligne en
cas de cas hélas j'ai regardé la vidéo
1080p sur un écran 4 cas c'est vraiment
agréable
comme je vous le dis j'ai une collection
internet ici vraiment vraiment pas
terrible donc bon on va pas profiter de
la meilleure qualité mais derrière si
vous avez de la fibre ça ira
parfaitement bien autre point qui est
aussi cool et qui pourrait malgré tout
malade s'en prenant ces qu'elle est
compatible google assistant amazon alexa
syrie bien évidemment vous avez digby
alors après à vous de comprendre ce que
vous allez pouvoir faire avec certaine
intelligence artificielle et pas avec
d'autres avec big build des pouvoirs
tout télécommande et il ya peut-être de
tout ce que vous ferez pas de la même
manière avec un google assistant avec
les majors d'alex en tout cas c'est
assez bien est ce qui est très
intéressant ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est
ce qu'on fait samsung est vraiment
ouverte sur cette télé vous allez pas
vous retrouver en tout cas c'est fermé
avec justin digby d'envoyer vous avez
apple tv
vous avez les différences assistant vaut
qu'on que l'on pourrait en tout cas
s'imaginer ne pas vous retrouver là
dessus donc ça c'est plutôt bien
gros coup dur pour samsung en plus ce
qui est assez cool c'est que vous avez
une télécommande qui est assez petite
somme toute sommaire vous faire plein
plein plein plein de choses avec
regardez ici petit bouton bixby ici
l'ambiance mode
lorsque vous voulez décrocher dire
mettre l'ambiance mode derrière la
voulez mais c'est très facile
là vous avez navigué au bas droite
gauche faites comme vous voulez le
bouton de recul le bouton home bouton de
lecture le bouton de volume se fit
pousser vers le haut ou vers le bas ça
vous montre le son la même chose pour
les chaînes ici vous montez vous baissez
vous avez un raccourci netflix vous avez
un raccourci prennent vidéo et vous avez
raccourcis rakuten tv voyez c'est tout
petite télécommande elle est sympa ça
c'est cool parce qu'elle a vraiment
compté près
comme cette télécommande facile simple
efficace ça marche parfaitement bien
maintenant si vous regardez que la télé
en année on regarde juste les bords ils
sont vraiment hyper hyper hyper x c'est
très simple très joli très profilé faut
que c'est pareil là dessus il ya un vrai
boulot qui a été fait vous avez des
côtes et légèrement biseautés c'est une
télé qui calmait pas très épaisse
regardez là alors il ya un côté un petit
peu arrondi à l'arrière mais elle est
quand même relativement pas énorme pour
venir la posez vous la posez contre un
support mural si vous voulez ça vous
donnera un rendu qui est vraiment bien
le son de la télé en elle-même est déjà
vachement bien mais en plus pas si vous
avez remarqué moi j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir aussi en prêt bien évidemment
toujours des enceintes harman kardon
enfin une enceinte une barre de son
doivent se dire un mannequin dont ainsi
qu'un caisson de basses qu'elles
justement alors le truc qui est cool
c'est que c'est vraiment hyper
transparence la qualité du son est bien
c'est très très très facile à brancher
via plusieurs modes sans fil avec lille
moi j'ai branché en hdmi
en gros j'ai une sortie hdmi là dessus
j'ai une entrée hdmi là dessus c'est
tout pas plus c'est très facile et votre
caisson de basses lui il va se connecter
directement sans fil vous pouvez
déplacer des portes et fenêtres comme
vous voulez c'est très très très simple
d'utilisation
comme sur la télé le design est
vachement bien alors c'est très très
très très très linéaire vous en douterez
vous y retrouver sur le dessus ici le
logo samsung
harman kardon vous avez ici un petit
écran qui est planqué alors il faut
venir avec la télécommande pour venir à
changer les chaînes vous voyez ici un
petit écran qui est en dessous qui avait
indiqué sur quel type d'entrée vous êtes
au niveau audio vous allez retrouver ici
sinon sur le dessus des boutons pour
venir changer la source si la
télécommande n'a plus de pistes vous
sauver la vie l'allumé baissé de monter
le volume ça c'est cool est sur le côté
ici j'ai mon subwoofer qui est là avec
les sox ont positionné sur le côté la
très simple efficace
sobre joli ça prend pas trop de place
mais par contre ça dégage quand même
beaucoup de sons la référence de la
barre de son c'est la hw tirer n 8 150
bars de son qui est très intéressante et
sur plusieurs points tout d'abord elle a
le dolby atmos l aider tsx elle est 5
points un point de l à 362 watts de
puissance
il ya une vraie effets de spatialisation
sens que par rapport au son de la télé
vous à l'écouté qu'il est déjà bien
comme ça en lui même mais lorsque vous
avez en plus cette barre de son avec le
caisson de basses vous avez une façon de
d'ouverture inspectent qui vous paraître
un peu comme ça au niveau de la taille
de la télé puis un groupe ça s'ouvre
c'est un très grand très large et pour
plusieurs raisons
notre mère raison c'est qu'en façade
bien évidemment vous avez ici vos
haut-parleurs twitter ça vous en
douterez mais en plus sur le dessus vous
avez ici là il est situé là si vous le
voyez un qui est juste là et son petit
frère qui est juste là qui vous projette
leçon au plafond donc là vous avez
vraiment du son qui va partir sur le
haut qui l'avenir arrivée qui va taper
et qui va redescendre de l'autre côté
donc ça c'est je dirais ça joue vraiment
la spatialisation offert quelques leçons
va venir vraiment tout autour de vous
mais ça s'arrête pas là vous avez en
plus de chaque côté un haut parleur et
vous avez son petit frère qui est juste
de l'autre côté qui est ici en fait
l'idée c'est que le son va arriver en
face de vous avec leoparleur vous avez
en face à des tweeters donc vous avez dû
sont vraiment en face de vous avez aussi
du son qui va partir directement de
chaque côté en eau qui va taper contre
un plafond qui va revenir vers vous qui
va jouer vraiment sur l'immersion mais
également le son qui par deux côtés et
qui va venir encore plus de nos stations
d'ouverture de son dock en gros vous
êtes complètement immergé leçon arrive
de devant en plus l'ouverture dé twitter
est assez large dont vous avez vraiment
une grande grande ouverture au niveau du
son dont qu'il arrive vraiment face de
vous il arrive au dessus de vous donc il
vient il replonge sans vous donc le son
arrivée au site derrière il arrive des
côtés ce qui fait que vous avez vraiment
quand vous êtes face à butt et que vous
regardez un film chéri ce que vous
voulez ça ouvre d'un coup et ça c'est
vraiment bien en plus vous avez le
caisson de basses qui vient un peu
ronronner apporte un kit de groovy ça
c'est aussi super cool et vous avez ces
technologies
uh plus 32 bits l'idée c'est que ça va
vous prendre votre signal audio qui peut
être en 8 bits jusqu en 24 bits et ça va
le transformer aux safa l'espèce deux
skype en 32 bits profiter d'une
meilleure qualité audio votre télé ici
va faire de l'obs quai au niveau de la
qualité pour vous ayez un rendu cap k
qui soit vraiment bien pour ta qu'a eue
hd vous allez la voir la même chose au
niveau de 32 bits au niveau de votre
barre de son harman carmaux vous avez
profitez d'une expérience en termes de
multimédia qui est vraiment incroyable
tout ça sans aucun reflet avec des
couleurs avec de la lui
avec un taux qui complètement sur un
petit musée c'est vraiment bien alors
bien évidemment tout ça c'est un coup
c'est pas non plus du matériel qui coûte
pas très cher on va pas se mentir on est
sur le site de samsung un peu moins de
3000 euros l'écran on voulait trouver un
peu moins cher c'est intéresse je vous
ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description il faudra sortir un peu
moins de 1300 euros
mais franchement la qualité est là et vu
la taille de la dalle c'est vraiment
énorme alors si vous voulez une dalle
inférieur cela coûtera également un peu
moins cher de france jusque là où nous
en outre m et au niveau de la barre de
fonte plus le caisson de basses j'ai
trouvé des tarifs qui vont osciller
entre 850 euros 1200 euros on trouve un
petit peu de tout une fois de plus de
1000 eu lien en bas de la description
vous allez jeter un petit coup d'oeil
et puis vous disent que vous en pensez
bien évidemment en bas en commentaire
alors cette télé cette barre de son don
est destiné à tout le monde vous
destinez vraiment personnes qui veulent
profiter d'une bonne expérience
multimédia avoir un superbe écran à bord
du sont vraiment très très bonne qualité
quelque chose de très immersif
il vous faut une grande pièce pour
pouvoir la regarder comme ça je vous le
dis ne faites plus en détail inférieures
c'est 65 pouces il ya le 55 pouces et xo
6 le 75 pouces mais la poisse tout
augmenterait de l'écran également le
tarif
mais là avec cette config l'asse votre
pièce peut le supporter vous serez
absolument pas déçu dites moi ce que
vous en pensez ça vous botte sa promesse
intéressant comme confie qu est-ce que
vous avez une télé samsung est ce que
vous pourriez avoir cet écran samsung
q l'aide 85 r pour moi c'est un petit
bijou
bravo bah si samsung et à bientôt ciao